[Music]
wake up buddy it is walk o'clock
maybe i should let him sleep
okay
[Music]
[Music]
and um okay
we'll go for a walk
i have an owner and he's superman let me
just turn that out
you should call me iron man
no
my dog is the best but he's not the
greatest with other animals what is new
with you fellow normal dog i bit the
fedex guy the other day who is he
working for general zod the legion of
doom
fedex of course the federation of exes
not to be trusted
what is taking my owner so long
well well well
if it isn't the justice league
superman
what's going on
you're super strong i should be a lot
more dead right now right
my best friend is in danger and you have
to help me well we're just a bunch of
shelter pets but they're stronger than
you think the mighty oil
i didn't see anything show on wheels
where the heck am i destructive dog
great i'm the only one who didn't get
any super power
when one has an abundance of power
they have a certain duty to use that
power to
sorry
you were saying something
how much did you have to drink i had two
toilet bowls end of a day but day two
which is which is crazy i didn't even
know that was a thing but it's like a
dog water fountain
oh out of the way cat child
hey deploy k-92 what is the k-9
invade
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
anybody want to switch powers
[Music]
bye